I found this video of shark tank
billionaire investor you know this guy
Mr Wonderful Kevin O'Leary he was on
Tucker Carlson's Fox Nation show and he
started talking about what's happening
in America it's obviously a theme I've
been talking about for quite some time
how the blue States simply are not
working anymore that if you just want to
create something whatever it is a
business you want to sell t-shirts you
want to open up a store you want to sell
freaking smoothies that it's just
becoming impossible to do in blue States
my whole life as an investor
30 plus years
95 of my money why they went to Silicon
Valley
or into Boston around MIT and Harvard
that was the birthplaces of venture
capital since 1954.
that's where it all went
you can't put money to work in either of
those places today
Massachusetts is at war with
entrepreneurship
Elizabeth Warren will punish you for
Success she will make sure you pay super
taxes if you're successful the
regulatory environment there is
prohibitive for business New York
even worse New Jersey forget about it
California is not in business you can't
do business there and they're leaving
like droves out of there so this
competition of states is beginning to
occur my whole point is there are go-to
States
and there's no ghost States and no go
States right now are New York New Jersey
Massachusetts California
you cannot invest in those places they
are no longer investable they're going
to have to change policy have you been
to San Francisco who in their right mind
right now is looking at those places and
being like yes I'm going to build a
giant Factory in New York I'm going to
employ all of these people in California
as he said California is just done so
they just keep moving and they keep
moving and then they take resources they
take it's not just money they take good
people that's what my lesson the lesson
of my life more than anything else in
the in the 15 or so months that I have
been here in Florida has been that from
all of the people I've met and the
people that came with me here it's not
just the money
that comes out of the blue States and
the money that you'll save here it
really is not it's the good people it's
the people who realize that they want
some autonomy over their lives and then
they move and they enrich the place they
go to and they leave the other one
they leave that Barren destitute land
where nothing's going to grow that's how
it is
[Music]